good day and welcome i'm jack van horn from
the university of virginia and i am delighted
to welcome you to this edition of our 2021 2022
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
series this lecture series is supported by uva's
integrated translational health institute of
virginia the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the national institutes
of general medical sciences this year's theme
is ethical challenges of artificial intelligence
and biomedicine where every friday we enjoy
presentations from leading thinkers about
the promise the opportunities and the
hurdles associated with ai applications in the
biomedical sciences selected participants in
our biomedical data science innovation lab
program will leverage these presentations as
vital material for our culminating in-person
grant project development workshop to be held
here in historic charlottesville virginia in june
today i am delighted to welcome our speaker dr
alison antes from washington university in st
louis alison is an associate professor and an
organizational psychologist with a focus on the
ethical conduct of research she is the assistant
director of the center for clinical and research
ethics where she co-directs a responsible conduct
uh community of research scholars teaches courses
um and holds other activities um for the folks
at washington university she also teaches
course courses on ethics and professionalism
in research as well as in biostatistics she has
a specific interest in the role of leadership
management practices and workplace behavior in
conducting high quality responsible research and
is interested in the societal impact of that
research in particular she has conducted her
own research on the best practices in ethics
education and the assessment of ethics courses
she is a co-investigator on the professional and
social issues in the so professional and social
issues lab which focuses on research examining
factors that foster and hinder research integrity
and practical interventions aimed at enhancing
professionalism and ethical decision making in
research in continuing our 2021-2022 biomedical
data science seminar series theme alison's
lecture today is entitled ethical interactions in
scientific teams as a foundation for ethical ai
alison's lecture will explore the individual
factors and the interpersonal dynamics
which influence shape and which guide the ethical
norms and behavior of scientific teams and she
will make the case that ethical interactions
within teams is essential for the ethical
development and deployment of ai innovations her
lecture will discuss challenges which arise in
multi-disciplinary teams and strategies for
navigating those challenges as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for recording
via youtube and if you are watching via youtube
thank you so much for joining us also our
specially selected 2021-2022 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions for alison
via the chat feature in their zoom sessions i'll
synthesize these questions i'll ask them at the
in the last 10 minutes or so of alison's lecture
and with that alison welcome we are so excited
to hear from you today uh we've really been
looking forward to your lecture thanks so much
hi and thank you for inviting me i'm pleased
to be here and i'm looking forward to
um sharing my talk with you today and then
getting some good discussion going towards the end
so just a great introduction
thank you so much for that
um this next slide here just shows you a
couple of um my papers looking at leadership
and management and research as you noted
and then i also do some work in the space of
public perceptions and research
participant and patient perceptions
of the use of ai and healthcare and as you
noted i'm at washington university in st
louis on the medical campus in the bioethics
research center which is our newer name um
and i conduct um empirical funded empirically
funded empirical research funded by nsf and nih um
in the center i also wanted to mention two of the
professional development and training programs
that i'm involved with involved in one is called
the professionalism and integrity and research
program this is a coaching program for researchers
who um have issues in their research laboratories
and their centers that they direct or um in their
teams and so today's presentation is going to pull
together my own experience as a researcher leading
a leading research and being a research team my
experience studying behaviors in the research
environment especially leadership and management
and my experience coaching researchers
who have challenges that come up
so examples would be issues with data
integrity that ultimately lead to retractions
issues with submissions that
lead to investigation by
central funding agencies so these researchers
are really looking to pick themselves back up
and get their careers back on track and we always
say that they're really great researchers and
they missed you know some of the details some of
the important features and then things escalate
and become problematic so i really like pulling
together what contributes to effective research
teams and then looking into these issues and these
challenges and thinking about how all these things
triangulate to these same kind of stories about
what contributes to effective ethical research
and then this other program i'm involved with
is so new that it doesn't even have a logo yet
and the name compass is mostly solidified
but we're still exploring and making sure
it's the way to go so this is a program that's
funded by nih to help train and develop junior
faculty and postdocs and leadership and
management skills as they're navigating
the early stages of their career so this will be
open nationally to all researchers who meet that
general criteria biomedical investigators um
and and who are junior faculty or post-doc
and um it'll provide training around leadership
and management skills and it'll also allow the
opportunity for mentoring both in peer groups and
from experienced researchers who have already been
there and done that so just wanted to tell you
about those programs and makes that point that
i'm pulling together my own research my own
experience and then my experience training
and developing researchers so what are we going to
do in this talk um i'm going to make the case that
ethical interactions within teams are essential
for the ethical development and deployment of
ai intervention so i'm going to talk about what
it what i mean by ethical interaction what does
that mean what does ethical interaction mean in
teams um then i'm going to make the point that
individual and team behaviors and dynamics drive
scientific excellent and ethical research and
innovation and i want to talk about what
do these behaviors and dynamics look like
and then finally i want to get practical
um i really like to do that where i take
my research and then i start looking at how do we
apply it so i'm going to give you some practical
suggestions and some tips and some guides some
checklists and talk you through that and hopefully
these will be of value to you in the future so
um i'm known in the center and on campus as the
relationships matter person um which i'm willing
to accept that as the as my um uh how i'm known
and soon you'll see why first i'd like to share
some statements with you for you to reflect on
when i have ideas i know that i can share them
and people will listen when i have concerns about
a project i feel comfortable bringing them up when
others share their work i know they value my input
and feedback i can count on team members to give
me constructive and valuable input and feedback
when something goes wrong my team members
band together to figure it out i feel like my
contribution matters to my team members something
bad happens in my life it's okay to say that i'm
struggling if something positive happens in
my life it's okay for me to express excitement
i'm not worried what others think of me
i feel that i can be myself in this team
so just reflect on those statements for a second
these are statements that a person in
a psychologically safe work environment
would make in this kind of environment you feel
and believe that your team expects you to speak up
that's just how your team does things you believe
others will give you the benefit of the doubt if
you challenge something take a risk or make a
mistake you're able to talk about problems and
concerns learn from failure and openly share
ideas no matter your status or hierarchy in
in the um in the team you can be
yourself without fear of judgment
just to say a little bit more about what is a
psychologically what is psychological safety at
work it's a shared belief held by members of the
team that others in the team will not embarrass
reject or punish you for speaking up um ccl is a
major center for creative leadership is a major
leadership development organization that's very
evidence-based and one of their chief officers
says people feel comfortable being themselves they
bring their full self to work and feel okay laying
all of themselves on the line so in this kind
of environment people feel they can voice un
undeveloped thoughts they're not fully formed yet
they can ask naive and seemingly random questions
they can brainstorm out loud and they can
give and receive constructive feedback
many of you have enough experience in the research
environment that you're starting to see wow those
seem like important features of um doing effective
science being able to have those things happening
um it is important to note this
doesn't mean that everyone is
is super positive and nice all the time like that
doesn't mean there's never any kind of conflict
or um clashing or tension that comes up it's
just that you can speak about it and you know
that you're going to work it through and that
your team has your back and you have their back
um and there's emerging work and conversation
around not only the importance of psychological
safety for fostering innovation and effectiveness
at work but also that it's fundamentally um about
inclusion because in order to be included and
feel like you can learn and grow and that you
can speak up and ask random questions you have to
have this kind of environment so it's really um
creating a kind of environment that establishes
all these features of what we're really hoping
to have in scientific teams we're hoping to
have people who feel like they can be their
whole selves they can bring all of their talents
and skills they can speak up they can ask good
questions and as you know this is even more
essential in multi-disciplinary teams because
you're all coming from different disciplines you
have different languages and so when someone uses
an acronym or jargon that you don't understand
you need to be like hey what the heck is that
i need you know that comfortability to speak
up and um ask those random questions and to
bring up those what if questions um as you're
going about your work so that's what it feels
like to be in this kind of environment that's what
psychologically safety feels like and that's what
it is at the individual level but what creates
psychological safety at work the short answer is
a positive team climate so positive team climate
is the basis of psychological safety at work and a
positive clean team climate um is characterized by
interpersonal interactions that have trust respect
openness transparency and honesty information
sharing exchange of perspectives and support
and you can see that yeah this is good for
people this makes people feel like they can
be their full selves it fosters well-being and
engagement and inclusion at work but it's also
essential to innovation a responsible science so
these features equal um ethical interaction and
we'll get in the weeds in a few minutes about
what are the behaviors and practices and the
things that need to be happening on the ground
day-to-day to create that kind of environment
so before i do that i want to just say a
little bit more about ethical ai development
so that kind of positive team climate with
those kinds of interactions are the basis
of ethical innovation and if you strip it all
the way back it's ultimately because we need to
hear all the voices all the time um across the ai
development pipeline from discovery to deployment
we need to hear from older and younger members of
our team all levels of experience all levels of
expertise from technicians to content experts and
also ethicists community members everybody with
different backgrounds like experiences cultures
and from different communities so that all of
the um considerations that need to be looked
at in designing and deploying these tools are
brought to the table and that everybody has equal
equal chance to bring up these concerns and bring
these ideas there because we're trying to solve
really complex problems in society with a lot
of these tools and a lot of ai development um and
the teams that are doing that are really complex
and my next slide i just
want to say a little bit more
about what is ethical data science
and ai innovation in biomedicine
so what does that mean to design deploy and
um design develop and deploy ai applications
and tools that are ethical lots of people are
trying to answer this question right now and um
i kind of tried to summarize what
i'm seeing in the literature this
isn't everything but this is a good
way to kind of start thinking about it
it's respect and benef it's developing ai
applications and tools that respect and
benefit the communities that provide
data and attend to their preferences
safely and equitably contributing to human
well-being health access and health outcomes
and adhering along the way to fundamental ethical
principles such as respect fairness privacy
non-discrimination transparency and ensuring
that we do good to others that we avoid harm
and that we provide benefit and following any
legal or regulatory requirements along the way
one of the challenges that we have right now in
the face of that legal and regulatory concerns
or related to some ai um innovations in the
use of big data and biomedicine lag behind
some of the technical advancements that we're
able able to um achieve at this time and so
it's going to be interesting to see in the next
five to 10 years how um globally and in the u.s we
address these this this problem but these concepts
i you know they resonate i assume they sound good
respect and benefit and safety and equity but
effort putting those ideals into practice requires
day-to-day behavior and that's sometimes difficult
to think about how do we take from this desire
researchers want to do good work that's 99.9 of
the time why they're doing the work they're doing
they want to do good work they want to do the
right thing they want to make a positive impact
on society and these are important and good
ideals but it requires that day-to-day practice
um and that's why i'm saying attending to
ethical interactions as just an absolute
fundamental component is a great first step in
the right direction i have one more slide that
takes us a little bit more on the detour
from the central emphasis on relationships
that i want to share with you because this is
sometimes a source of confusion um for researchers
i was going to say maybe especially early career
researchers but i would just say researchers in
general so my colleague and i wrote this paper
where we were talking about when people talk about
ethics and research depending on the stakeholders
focus sometimes they mean different things
um and it can kind of cause a sense of confusion
of like what am i looking at here in the space so
we argue that in today's um environment there
are kind of five ways that people mean it mean
research ethics so there's normative ethics so
that's like your traditional maybe philosopher
ephesus they look at the classic sense of
determining what's right and wrong in biomedicine
trying to establish dining principles of what
makes an action or activity and the biomedical
states acceptable or unacceptable so that's
sort of that philosophical what's right or wrong
then some stakeholders in the research
environment especially institutional officials
they think about compliance making
sure that we follow applicable
applicable research regulations laws rules and
policies such as insuring and consent forms
ensuring consent that's another way that research
ethics is kind of conceptualized and me and again
it goes back to stakeholders um the third is the
idea that we've got to do science that's reliable
and trustworthy and that our methods must be found
so you guys have seen as young researchers the
emphasis on rigor and reproducibility that's just
exploded in the last five to seven maybe 10 years
my time concept is a little different now that the
pandemics happened two years i think probably five
seven to ten years now um another dimension that's
been emphasized we wrote this paper in 2018 and
i've only seen it explode um especially with the
pandemic the meaning that ethical research is
research that has social values so it's addressing
problems important to society and engaging
relevant stakeholders and doing so in a way that's
equitable and addressing um providing benefit to
the communities and the people that really
need that that benefit um and then the fifth is
kind of the thrust of the presentation
today which is workplace relationships so
there's a risk to science when relations
when relationships sour and we must really
genuinely care about the perspectives of multiple
stakeholders in research particularly as we're
trying to tackle even more complex problems with
more complex methods so i'm essentially arguing
that there's these multiple meanings of research
ethics and sometimes that can make it confusing
for researchers like exactly what are we
talking about but all of these are important
for ai um ethical ai development and deployment
and the other point is that we were arguing this
paper that the way we treat each other ethical
interactions is an ethical issue in and of itself
and you're seeing that more and more um even among
calls for proposals among nih wanting to know how
are you going to establish a safe and supportive
work environment how are you going to provide for
an inclusive environment where everybody's talents
are able to be developed and able to be brought
to the table so the point is that this is both a
component of ethical research and it fosters all
of the other pieces so that's why i really focus
on it today but in some of my practical advice
and checklist i'm really speaking to multiple
of these different meanings of ethical research
so going back that was my kind of detour to what
is ethical aai and one of these different meanings
of research ethics going back to this idea we
need to hear all voices across the ai development
pipeline to achieve ethical innovation most people
agree with this but this is a classic scenario
easier said than done um the same things that
make innovation possible having younger and
older perspectives having different levels of
expertise engaging different content experts
community members episodes technicians people
with different backgrounds the same thing that
makes innovation possible also makes it
hard um doing this well it takes intention
it takes interpersonal skills and it takes
leadership skills and i i know that you've heard
sort of this theme at least in one or two other of
the talks that you've um had in this series i was
able to see some good presentations and so i'm
just i guess i'm here to say i agree and to add
um just to kind of go a little bit further
down this path of what gets in the way
of cultivating positive interpersonal interactions
in team climate one is time time is finite
resource and it takes some time to attend to
these matters and prioritizing it as something
that's essential to doing good research um most
of us are are over extended and limited time and
we often think about building relationships maybe
that doesn't feel like it's getting work done
and we have so many requirements and demands
on us that we kind of focus on the duty and do
test tasks and even the you know the nature
of communication and meetings can sort of
get a little bit um less than desirable when
you're just so strapped for time you're just
trying to get down in the nuts and bolts you can
be shorter with people for example without even
really meaning to or having any ill intent lack of
adequate team planning coordination and leadership
again some of that is because it takes
time and prioritization also it takes
skills and many of us are not trained in these
aspects of doing research and the reason that
planning and coordination and leadership are
essential to interpersonal interactions is
it's nearly impossible if not impossible to have
a positive team climate if people don't have
clarity about their role and they don't have
access to the information that they need and
the resources and the tools and the help
and the sport and the team interaction that
they need to actually be effective and they're
what they're trying to contribute to the team
so you have to get that the team dynamic
of the planning and the coordination right
um when you're trying to ensure that you
create positive interactions in team climate
the third point is
that we lack sort of just the pants to
sit back and think about communication
strategies and perspective taking um so i'm
going to talk a little bit about that in the um
in a few minutes and just the lack of know-how
that about how to cultivate these interactions
because it hasn't been as much emphasized in the
last you know and training scientists and now it's
just exploding in terms of what people are talking
about it's important which is which is good to see
um but on the upside um scientists have curiosity
and they have an eagerness to learn and i think
that that puts us into a great position to um
start to think about how do we make the time how
do we prioritize how do we how are we going to
be affected with team planning and coordination
how to be effective with leadership and
communication so that's sort of my um pep talk
this slide here tries to sort of conceptualize
building from some of the literature of like
what are all the features that go into a effective
scientific team um on the left with box one that's
your team structures like who's what disciplinary
knowledge are you bringing to the table
what expertise and background are you bringing
to the table what are the roles and what's the
composition of the teams maybe it's multi-teams
um contributing to a larger collaboration and
what are the project goals and objectives so
that's your research planning and team formation
and then i'm going to jump before what are we
trying to achieve we're trying to have some
productivity quality of work innovation
ethical research and we're trying to
um create an environment where people feel
a sense of contribution and satisfaction and
then in the middle of what i'm sharing with you
today this idea that we need to create space for
team planning and maintenance and we need to
think about individual behaviors and that's
individual behaviors bucket i'm going to focus on
communication strategies and perspective taking
and in the team behaviors and norms bucket i'm
going to share with you practical advice around
establishing goals and expectations
information sharing and participation
productive conflict shared communication norms
and leadership and i have this gray sort of box um
to represent positive team climate so positive
team climate is both um created by the behaviors
and norms in both of these two blue boxes the team
behaviors and norms and the individual behavioral
norms and it's also reinforced by and then those
behaviors and norms are also reinforced by taught
as a positive team climate so sort of
like a self-fulfilling feedback loop where
creating a good environment fosters even more of
the things we want and doing the things we want
creates that kind of environment and that's why
if we start with team planning and goal setting
up front and try to be strategic and
intentional we're better able to think
about creating the kind of environment that
we want to see so now i'm going to shift
so let's get practical so as i mentioned on
that last slide with the two boxes in the middle
i'm going to talk about team behaviors and norm
and i'm going to talk about individual behavior
so in the team behaviors and norms section
i pulled together a checklist built from
my research and from some of the research on
multi-disciplinary collaboration and team science
um i tried to pull together a checklist that
would represent important um features and and
components of team planning and maintenance
over time um i think it has it has 10 items
i pulled together a team checklist a team kickoff
checklist sort of that initial meeting that you
might have or it may even take a couple
meetings um to really kick off and then i
pulled together a team ethics checklist at the
risk of making ethics look like it's separate
from one and two rather than integrated i wanted
to kind of spell out what are the kinds of things
we can be doing in scientific teams to think about
ethics in the day-to-day on the ground day-to-day
practice and then for individual behaviors i
have example statements of um for communicating
different types of things that you would need
to communicate in scientific teams and these
would be relevant to individual team members
across the spectrum and especially relevant to
um team leaders because team leaders set the tone
they lead by example so having these statements
coming from team leaders helps to foster that
sort of like okay that's how we do things here
um and then i'm gonna talk a little bit about
perspective taking as an underlying important
thrust and um skill in interpersonal
interaction and communication style
okay so i'm going to split this
checklist this team planning and
maintenance checklist into two slides 10
items total um and then on the right side
i kind of tried to illustrate the domain
that i'm speaking to with each of these
items and i created this so that it reflects
both team planning so our team has a plan for
and then our team had which would be maintenance
more of a long-term ongoing component where you
would want to continue to have these things
in place and evaluate them over time so um
the first two are are related to meetings what's
the plan for um meetings what's the frequency
and what's the agreed upon modality um having
meeting agendas and note-taking to document
important decisions that are made in
meetings maybe you don't actually need like
verbatim meeting notes but documenting decisions
and issues that are coming up um is becoming even
more and more important as teams get bigger and
collaborations become more complex so i really
want to emphasize the value of these two things
and um in my experience coaching researchers the
things i've seen happen when teens don't need
enough you go off and do your tasks and it's
like oh we don't have time to meet and there's
definitely a world in which you can meet too much
um but even if you're doing 15 30 minute check-ins
with individuals or the collective team meetings
really provide a lot of value um and are a good
use of time if you're able to make make them
effective then i have what's the plan for
coordination of day-to-day activities and then
any kind of daily ad hoc as needed
communication within the team um
what's the plan for making sure that there's
clarification for all team members regarding
what their roles and expectations are and that
we revisit them over time and then the last is
really valuable strongly recommend some kind of
team operating manual or collaborative agreement
describing the plan the expectations
essentially how the team as members will operate
i'll say a little bit more about this um
in a minute because this is something that
you could actually go over in a kickoff
and also the other thing i'll
say i'll go ahead and say it now
it's important to have something like this
but it doesn't matter if no one knows it
exists or you don't discuss it collaboratively
or there's no sort of shared buy-in that like
this is a thing we have that helps guide our
operations and we should know it exists and be
sensitive to it and even it can change and grow
over time so now i'll move on to six through ten
and these focus on first you
focus on leadership and management
so what's the plan for how leaders and manual
who will oversee progress and interact with um
each other so if you have multiple teams or
project teams or that are being managed you
got to have a consideration of how those different
projects are going to interact with each other um
over time to both discuss project milestones
but also just how the teaming process is working
an essential component of leading and managing
science that is really time consuming and is hard
is there's got to be some sort of structure and
plan for leaders and managers who are verifying
that the plans and the procedures that we've
agreed to operationally are being followed um
that there's feedback being provided on
the science itself and the procedures
and that any obstacles that are that arise um are
removed and trying to do that proactively versus
reactively is really key being conscious
about a plan number eight for training and
professional development for all team members
to foster their effectiveness and their rules
and then ongoing ongoing team process quality
improvement with time explicitly set aside for
this maybe it's every once a month at first or
once every six weeks or once a quarter or once
every six months or once a year once you're
really going but looking at what's our process
quality improvement and taking time to reflect
on that even something as simple as like are
we meeting enough are we meeting too
much should we restructure our team
meetings are the wrong people at the meetings
do we need other people at the meeting
those are important issues that
need to be reflected on over time
and then number 10 onboarding onboarding
onboarding this is something scientific tend
to struggle with a bit because it is really time
intensive but bringing everybody into the fold
in terms of daily operations again how are
we going to function and one of the tricks
here is that the team can change over time so
people are offboarding and onboarding especially
when you think about students and trainees
who are contributing to scientific projects
and that newcomer doesn't have the same
perspective as the person that's been there
and trying to get them up to speed takes a lot
of intention especially if maybe the kickoff was
truly a kickoff for the beginning of a four-year
project or five-year project or even a two-year
project now you don't have another kickoff um how
do you get that newcomer up to speed that's where
your operating manual your collaborative agreement
that spells out rules expectations can provide
sort of this living document that is
something that can be used for onboarding
during a kickoff and then onboarding
newcomers over time and then my last check
list item is just to kind of remind you this is
not necessarily 100 exhaustive nor will it meet
everybody's needs but these are really essential
features that i would strongly encourage that
you're thinking about team planning and then
maintenance over time so now i'm gonna move to
i think it's a nine point checklist related
team um kickoff meeting so a team kickoff
all of this is really in that
domain it's in multiple domains
like coordination projects team coordination
communication leadership and onboarding so
here's my recommendations of the things you would
want to ensure that you're covering a kickoff
you've discussed all plans norms and
expectations on the team planning and
maintenance checklists so like you've discussed
everything that's on the prior thing that you've
already kind of spelled out and defined about
operations and how the team's going to function
you've shared and discussed that operating
manual or collaborative agreement
and this could be revised or additions could be
could be added with input even that comes up in
the checklist like hey i noticed this why don't
we think about adding this idea or how are we
going to navigate different issues that come up
heard from the project leadership and management
team about their leadership and teamwork style
and philosophy sort of setting some of that
groundwork for that climate that you're trying
to create up front one of the things that um
effective leaders do is they say out loud what
they value prioritize and care about and so i just
can't emphasize enough the value of just a few
sentences a few words um it doesn't have to be a
uh you know an hour-long speech a few sins
and a few words about um how you want the team
um work the team environment to look and
function and how that's really important to you
to hear from everybody and have everybody's with
that table um really helps to foster that sense of
what are we trying to achieve here in terms
of the way we're going to work as a team um
four communicated about the known strengths
and limitations of the disciplines involved and
anticipated potential sources of past conflict so
actually getting people engaged in conversations
around how their disciplines function technically
and how their disciplines operate and see the
world is really really valuable because you're
you only know your discipline you only know your
kind of lens your experience and starting to have
people think about the strengths and limitations
of their own discipline is really valuable and
then having that cross talk about that especially
if you're engaging people that you're not used
to collaborating with such as social scientists
or ethicists um having everybody getting to
speak up like this is how my discipline works
and why and how and here's some limitations
really starts to get people to understand sort
of okay we're not all coming out it's the same
that's what we want again the things that make
scientific multi-disciplinary teams effective and
able to animate are also the things that make it
make it hard at times um point five is hearing
from all team members at all levels about their
experience or their expertise and their interests
so that other team members know if you bring
together all the greatest technicians and all
the greatest contact experts and all the experts
that you can to achieve the research goals but
people don't know who has what expertise or
what interest it makes it hard to tap into the
right expertise at the right time so creating
that shared mental kind of understanding of who
knows what and also just who's interested in what
because sometimes project needs come up where
somebody's willing to tackle a new aspect of a
project or explore a new issue and that's just
something that they're just kind of like a pet
think and they get that opportunity and that helps
develop people within the team and engage them and
make them feel like they're contributing
okay and then my last six through nine
whenever we write research proposals if
you're doing research that's funded we
establish goals and objectives we
establish milestones and timelines
but i can't tell you i mean most of you
have done projects so you've probably seen
this like you have it written and you wrote it
and it looked beautiful and it scored well and
it's awarded but you still have to revisit those
because everyone didn't necessarily see that last
uh and wasn't necessarily involved with writing
all the elements of the proposal and also things
shift and change over time it's been months since
you wrote that so revisiting it is really valuable
um versus just like saying go read the proposal
everything you need to know is there it's a great
idea to have everyone read the proposal but
also establishing and re-establishing goals
objectives milestones timelines is really
valuable um discussing as a group ethics as
a priority and the ethical concerns and issues
that we think might be relevant to our projects
so um again i said before researchers want to
do the right thing they care about research they
about research ethics and they care about
their work having an impact on society and
and being of value um and i mentioned that
those ideals are fantastic the trick starts
to become how do we make that happen in the
day-to-day on the ground with our own projects
so prioritizing it and discussing it explicitly
is one important step in the right direction there
i said before talk about your disciplines
and possible areas of task conflict eight
is a very related concept discussing
potential challenges um in the teams
like different languages and jargon and the
disciplines that are represented across the team
and then nine this goes back to establishing
expectations for the team environment from the
beginning talking about how um there's negative
forms of conflict and positive forms of past
conflict and we want to minimize the negative and
encourage debate and productive conflict and how
that's actually critical to innovating um
and achieving the project goals so again
saying out loud some of these things that those of
us who have worked in the research environment no
to be true because we've seen them over time but
making it explicit for everyone and um is really
helpful when we're taking off the project and then
my next and final checklist for you guys it's an
ethics checklist i went ahead and crammed this
all into one slide so forgive me for the wordiness
i tried to bold although i'm not sure it
shows up that well in this life the key
pieces of each of these elements um this is not
exhaustive but these are some of the key features
and again these points cross those
five dimensions of compliant broader
rigor and research normative
ethics issues so the first is
maybe there's an agenda item at team
meetings or at least some routine
meeting focused on broader consequences
of data and analysis practices
we discuss at team meetings emerging
or potential ethical concerns
team leaders talk about ethics and the value of
it and research rigor as an essential priority
when doing the work this fourth one
is one if you do have compliance elements
to your research project it's important that
even though we know that sometimes compliance
elements to a project especially if you're using
human data that's not de-identified and you
have to get um an irb involved can be burdened
it's just a reality um but the way we talk about
compliance within our project teams really does
start to shape an attitude around what it means to
be a responsible scientist and we found in some of
our work that kind of keeping a positive attitude
even even if acknowledging oh this is frustrating
or a burden but seeing it as an essential part of
doing um good responsible research is of important
it relates pretty well to um this idea of the two
down about regarding compliance offices resources
and staff as supporters of research not after
adversaries so i do some other work talking to the
people on that side of the scientific enterprise
the people who are interested in compliance and
regulation and one of their biggest um notes is
sometimes researchers see us as like adversaries
when really we're trying to support research we're
trying to ensure that researchers are able to
do research in a way that complies with rules
and regulations and keeps them out of trouble
keeps their team out of trouble and keeps our
institution out of trouble and allows us to be um
accountable to to these roles into the public
and create trust um i have listed here engaging
ethicists throughout the entire research life
cycle um especially especially from the beginning
but really throughout and if you're identifying
potential consequences that are of concern
um in in in a project bringing them in at some
point um is really something to consider and is
important and contribute to your guys's ability
to sort through the issue engaging community
stakeholders whenever feasible but getting
perspectives outside of the research team
if you've never worked with community members
or other stakeholders outside of
the team on a project it's just so
illuminating to hear from them and their um
their vantage point because they can bring up
broader consequences or questions that can really
affect our thinking about the problem or are
thinking about the data and bringing those voices
up in when possible along this life cycle um
is really valuable the last few points i have
one about authorship because we're all um tend
to be pretty conscious of authorship credit
and so discussions that are explicit about that
isn't um are valuable and then the last two
documentation documentation documentation
written procedures written procedures
written procedures say that three times um
again this goes back to prior organization
and time we're rushing through but project
teams need standards and written procedures
that are also monitored and followed up on
for data everything data data documentation data
security data sharing data backup everything along
a date of life cycle along the pipeline we've
got to have expected standards and procedures
for that and be checking in that our team is
following those and again if the project has any
research compliance requirements having
standards and written procedures for
um following those requirements and documentation
that those requirements have been followed
is really valuable um especially in large complex
multidisciplinary teams so those are all of my um
practical tips related to team behaviors and norms
and trying to kind of drill down like what would
be the practices and the things we would need
to be attending to and then my next few slides
speak to the individual so it's going to
feel like a shift but it's intentional so
now we're going to shift and on this first
slide i have communication functions on the
left and i have example statements on the right
and these are sort of more of your task focused
communication so i have encouraging participation
managing conflict handling mistakes and clarifying
expectations and i have an asterisk there
especially good for managing up so the conflict is
the concept of managing up you may have heard of
it from people call it like managing your boss
what could be managing your mentor um is
the idea that sometimes people who are um
the is the idea that you're using skills like
some of these communication skills to bring
out the best in yourself as a member of the team
so i say that clarifying expectations is really
useful for managing up because sometimes when
you're depending on where you are on the team
there there just simply may be unclarified
expectation you may not you may be concerned
that you're not on the same page so having these
strategies of asking directly is really valuable
to trying to get that kind of clarification so
i'm now just going to give an example or two
for each of these um hopefully these slides will
be a resource reference for you in future which
i'm happy to share i'm happy to share them
so encouraging participation imagine sitting
around a meeting table asking what are we missing
what other suggestions do you have um saying this
is new for us we need everybody's input managing
conflict um i think these are all nice statements
it seems like we're seeing this differently will
you tell me more about your perspective on this
um if it's a little contentious you could say i
know we're not seeing eye to eye on this issue
now but i'm optimistic we can work it out if it's
even more contentious and uncomfortable starting
the conversation when you're in a more tense kind
of conflict is often the hardest part so you could
start with it is difficult for me to raise this
concern and ish and wow whatever issue may not be
intentional this is upsetting for me let's talk
about it more um and then the last one is just
i appreciate the opportunity to explore this
issue with you handling mistakes some of the
work i've done has shown that the way that project
teams and project team leaders handle mistakes
is really um a key feature in creating a
psychologically work safe work environment
because remember part of that is
knowing like if you do mess up that
you're going to be able to raise that issue and
talk about it and i've seen um lack of front end
well uh lack of handling mistakes well early on
ballooning into problems in in my experience
coaching researchers so when a mistake is
comes to um the forefront saying something
like what can we do to resolve this problem
what can we learn from this or if it's let you
know if you're like really down about it which
i think this is almost exactly something i said
within the first month of one of the projects i
i launched recently because one of the newcomers
to the team into the center made a mistake
his face was just so upset and i was like this is
not how we hoped this launch of this recruitment
feature our recruitment process of the project
would go but we'll figure it out and his whole
face changed like okay she's she's not angry but
i was not happy either so that's why i was like
not how we hoped it'd go but we'll figure it
out um then things for clarifying expectations
be things like let me let me repeat
what i think we're planning to do
then we can discuss or fill in any
guess and there's other examples there
the second list of communication um functions
these are more relationship focused so
definitely the way you handle those task
focused communications on the previous slide
um influence and inform relationship building
but these are more expressly about relationships
expressing appreciation i really appreciate your
work on this providing support and encouragement
what what helps you need or you can do this i'm
confident in you and then just connecting with
people just getting to know people for who they
are what are the biggest and who are the biggest
influences on your career so far and why what
do you like most about this project or this work
and then perspective taking is sort of like the
cognitive twin of emotional empathy
where empathy is like a more affective
you're feeling other people's feelings and
perspective taking is sort of imagining
what how another person sees a situation and
these are really underlie a lot of communication
conflict resolution and interpersonal
interaction so i wanted to take a second to say
um a few words about some of the questions you can
be asking yourself so one is one is to just test
your assumptions what assumptions am i making here
what evidence do i have for my thoughts to believe
um next is just imagining the other person's view
so how might this person think or feel about this
situation problem or issue and then the last one
is to really self-reflect on things like what am i
really concerned about here what do i really care
about am i admitting the limits of my knowledge
here how could i be deceiving myself these are
sort of those internal sort of the thoughts
and questions that you have in your own mind as
you're going through these interpersonal dynamics
and now i'm reaching towards the last few
slides and here's a other tips i always give
early career researchers so you've been told to
develop your network i'm just here to say yes
do not underestimate the value and importance
of developing your network early and often
cultivate multiple mentors don't expect one
or two people to be the super mentor that can
provide you with all the mentoring you need and
also go to peers peers provide great mentoring
learn to seek help and outside
perspective or expertise
know the resource the resources available
to your institutions you can tap into them
this is so hard learn to say no ask people you
really respect for more senior to you how they've
done it um you can get some good insights don't
forget to celebrate successes and small wins
along the way because our research is is a lot
of work it's hard there's a lot of setbacks so
forget not forgetting to stop and celebrate even
if it's in a small way and that also builds um
team relationships to say yeah guys we nailed it
okay now i'm on the next thing attending distress
in my coaching experience with researchers
when stress and anxiety get out of control
it's just really difficult to show up and be
your best self and it's very difficult to be an
effective leader and to cultivate relationships
and scientific teams when you're stretched so
thin that you're just constantly operating on the
pressure all the time and relatedly monitor your
self-talk and practice self-compassion so this is
the idea is listen to the things you tell yourself
so an example would be negative self-talk would
be something like i've never done this before and
i'll be bad at it and positive would be something
like this is a wonderful wonderful opportunity for
me and i'm going to learn from it and grow and
practice self-compassion as the idea and i feel
like it's useful to say this after two years of a
pandemic is the idea that you treat yourself with
the unkindness with the same kindness you would
treat others so giving yourself a break um and
saying no you did your best you're good you're
gonna get this you're gonna get through this
just giving yourself kindness this is a list
of references that kind of i've used in this
presentation and that are useful future future
reading for you guys um a lot of these if they if
you that title resonates i encourage you to take
a peek some of them are short to action invest
the time to prioritize in this human dimension
of doing research involve ethicists and social
scientists and projects and have ethics related
discussions throughout all phases last but not
least i'm going to leave you with three quotes
this first quote was actually something that
one of my coaching clients said when he
had this i saw the lightbulb moment like
i really feel like i saw it we were in
a zoom call he was like i just realized
the problems that happened in my research center
had to do with the dynamics of our team and the
way people were interacting and he said it kind
of makes me think of that maya angelou quote
people will forget what you said people will
forget what you did but people will never forget
how you made them feel so we spent the rest of our
coaching time together kind of trying to reverse
engineer how do you create a psychologically
safe um positive team climate and this is a
good reminder he cared about his people it was
clear it was just he had never attended to this
he hadn't taken the time he hadn't had training
he said i wish i'd had this training 20 years ago
so it's just becoming really really more and
more important and then i have two quotes from
researchers who are part of a study that i did
and i think that they're good ending points one is
rule number one is harmony first and foremost we
have to get along we have to respect each other
we have to trust each other and then the last
one is i try hard to be human i was human first
and then i learned to be a scientist so for so if
i forget the human part then that's the problem
and i worry about that all the time because the
pressure's on us and it's so enormous you forget
with that we have a few minutes for
discussion question alison thank you so much
all of your tips come at a very important time
for our biomedical data science innovation lab
participants because here in middle of june
we're going to be meeting here in charlottesville
and many of them don't know each other they're
coming from different kind of universities and
different lab cultures and different disciplines
some are biomedical some are ethicists some are
computer scientists and engineers ai specialists
what not we're going to toss them into this big
vat of intellectual awesomeness and we're going to
stir it all up and out of that we're really hoping
that these new multi-disciplinary teams are going
to emerge around topics of mutual interest and
they're going to pursue these to hopefully take
them through to either a really nice peer-reviewed
publication or hopefully even better uh an nih
grant around the topic that they have chosen but
because of this kind of i don't know accelerated
process some of these tips are really going to be
important that they think about as they're forming
these uh groups because within you know zero to
five days they're gonna all of a sudden be working
with a bunch of people they've never met before
so all of these are really really important
in the normal process when a you know i don't
know a grant is forming and whatnot you've got
a year to worry about it before the grant's due
is that process any different than one that's a
little more compressed like you know say five days
how do would you see the the time frame being
uh an important variable yeah
that's a really interesting question
so you don't have to have an answer that's
okay yeah yeah and that that compressed format
you really have to reach some sort
of mutual understanding and comfort
and sense of comfort sharing ideas pretty quickly
yeah exactly and we you know through the process
i'm hoping that people will kind of get there
but they're still the just the general things of
of understanding each other about how they make
each other feel um and you know one of the things
we've worked very hard on is to try to identify
folks who are really interested in team science so
we've sort of self-selected people from the get-go
but uh yeah so building in that self-selection
will help but two things come to mind it's just
being really intentional about how you could get
to know each other quickly and start to feel
comfort so two ways to do that would be to
write even just a half page or one page bulleted
point nothing that's going to take all day like
team charter or like kind of team philosophy
together to get talking about like how are
we going to make this work and just hear
each other's ideas another idea would be
i wouldn't want to call it an icebreaker per se
because this just always has this negative like oh
icebreaker but like some kind of activity i was
in a training program at cold spring harbor labs
and the first thing we did was get in small groups
so you could have the groups get in this group
and we talked about stories that had happened
in our scientific career that taught us things
that we'll never forget around interacting
in scientific teams some of our stories were
positive and some were like horror stories um
and man we bonded it was like group therapy
and we just became instantly close in that cohort
of about 30 people and then we were in smaller
teams of like four or so so just being intentional
about how to get people talking early and quickly
um just to get to know each other as people and
in their experience in a scientific environment
and then maybe doing like a short simple
activity of like how are we gonna make this work
how are we gonna make sure we hear everybody's
voices who's here at the table who do we have here
what's important yeah what's important to keep the
energy going i mean you you kind of mentioned you
know a lot of meetings documenting things um
you know what else can one do to kind of keep
the energy going after because usually when
you start something there's a lot of energy
and it's like maintaining that is always such a
challenge any recommendations yep so i do agree
i do think having some kind of routine meeting
schedule that we're gonna have and then just say
we're gonna touch base every two weeks or every
month or every week depends on your project and
what your goals are but having that scheduled
and then you can always say no we need we need to
you can always cancel it but i am of the mind if
it's not on your calendar not on your agenda it's
not going to happen and for at least the way
we operate in our center having those meanings
create sort of momentum and accountability so um
you know no one really loves to have like an extra
meaning but if you really care about a project and
a team making the time for that is really useful
acknowledging that you could cancel it if you
wanted it to um and the other is maybe in that
team charter like who is what are our roles
like who is leading this team are we leading it
collectively that shared leadership that might be
fine but sometimes that creates challenges where
you don't really know who's moving the baton or
who's responsible for scheduling the next meeting
or who's responsible for checking in on what so
clarifying that i think helps the momentum going
um maybe you expressly say one of our challenges
is going to be keeping our momentum going who's
going to be the momentum checker like who's
going to be the cheerleader who's going to be the
champion like does anyone want that role and maybe
their role is to say a few words at each meeting
or to send out just a brief email of some kind
to just keep people connected and i think that
one positive thing with the coveted pandemic
has been we are more familiar now with keeping
connected remotely and through digital devices and
through remote meetings so leveraging some of that
connectivity that we've learned to be able to do
without being in person um using it wisely for our
project teams i think can can really be a benefit
i think one of the things which is interesting is
that as we start to change from a pandemic based
you know remote interaction model and coming back
together to meet in person we're going to have to
relearn some of those group dynamics that you know
we may have i don't know we're out of practice and
so it'll be interesting an interesting experiment
with our innovation lab activities to kind of see
if people remember how to actually talk to one
another in person that's i think your tips are
going to be very very helpful uh as they do so
i've heard people talking about having to
keep eye contact and how that's unusual
and that could be your icebreaker your group team
building of like wow we're together this is so
exciting but it also feels awkward like being
vulnerable and saying i feel like it's weird to
keep eye contact with you right now and is a way
to build connection just to start the conversation
i love it we may have to do that as a
as a as an icebreaker we'll see alison
thank you so much for sharing your your uh
perspective with us on on how to do this
uh we'll be going through this little experiment
ourselves here in about a month and a half and
we're really looking forward to it actually alison
thank you so much everyone have a wonderful friday